very little is known about the gulper  eel this camera-shy deep-sea fish is  sometimes called the Pelican eel because  of the strange things it can do with its  mouth researchers were based out of the  Azores Islands where they have been  studying underwater species for almost  30 years they boarded a submarine and  plunged 1,000 meters below the surface  of the water then they waited this is  the first time the Pelican eel has been  seen directly by humans hunting for prey  [Music]  an early video from an unmanned  submarine showed the crazy mouth move  but this video is the first evidence  that Pelican eels actually pursue their  prey and don't just hang out in the  water waiting for it to fall into their  mouths the scientists hope their footage  will help us to better understand the  behavior of the pelican eel and shine  some light on how and why it evolved its  balloon-like head  [Music]  you  [Music]